okay so the marvel cinematic universe is
a bit of an anomaly in hollywood at the
moment marvel studios have somehow
managed to craft 34 projects that all
interconnect with each other and due to
telling this ongoing story they've
somehow built a massive franchise that
delivers success after success once the
mcu started to take off a lot of studios
tried to get in on it too but where
foggy succeeded they all failed this has
happened every single time with us
constantly seeing studios announce they
have a shared universe on the way that
ultimately ends up never getting off the
ground but why is it so difficult to do
even dc who have a similar structure and
character roster as marvel do have found
it difficult to catch up to them and
there's way more dead universes right
now then they're all live ones now
throughout this video we're going to be
taking a deep dive on the strategies
that marvel have used and also going
over why so many other studios don't
understand the key fundamentals this
video was inspired by the warner
brothers discovery investicle last week
in which david zazlev talked about how
dc are putting a 10-year plan in place
that will mimic marvel studios it's
something that the corporation has tried
to do before and i'm actually really
surprised that they're going this route
both the batman and joker were released
to both critical and financial success
and with them being standalone although
they try and focus on something like
that for the foreseeable future it seems
that the studio are not learning from
the lessons of the past and though i
don't just want to show all over the
company in this video i think it's
interesting to study why fergie
succeeded where so many have failed i
think there's going to be a lot of
opinions over this so if you agree with
us then please hit the thumbs up button
and down if you don't there's also the
comments too if you want to leave your
thoughts and without the way let's get
into it now in order to talk about this
we first have to go back to what things
were like in 2008. every time i've
talked about this on a video i've always
had some 15 year old either say i'm
talking
oh i'm completely rewriting history to
make things up but i was there i was
there one thousand years ago now iron
man believe it or not was a seedless
character back in 2008 and no one really
expected to do that well sure they
thought the movie would come out and be
okay but absolutely no one expected a
multi-billion dollar franchise to be
launched off the shoulders of tony stark
i think that this is the first major
thing that a lot of studios forget when
launching their own universes and it's
ultimately why they also panic and
eventually fail during the 90s marvel
sold off their most popular characters
and because of this they lost the movie
rights to the x-men spider-man fantastic
four hulk and a lot more they were
pretty much left with the characters
that no one wanted and because of this
there was absolutely no real pressure on
any of their stuff performing well if
iron man did more than okay it would be
seen as a big success because there was
no belief by the mainstream in the film
now this was the complete opposite to
how things are with dc because batman
superman and wonder woman are all
household names it instantly becomes a
problem if they underperform even
slightly we saw it in the case of man of
steel and batman v superman where having
these characters not completely break
the bank made the exacts panic and we
all know how justice league turned out
now marvel slowly started put the pieces
in place to build the avengers and they
helped out on universal's incredible
hulk dropped iron man 2 thor and then
captain america because they hadn't
invented the shared movie universe yet
there was no pressure on them to connect
films so when stuff wasn't a massive
success it didn't matter all that much
now if you look at the box offices for
the phase one films then they're all
pretty modest in comparison to what will
come down the line and this lack of
expectations meant that feige and co
didn't shut the bed and divert from
their overall plan nowadays studios
announced their entire 10-year plan
before they've even made the first movie
so they put the pressure on themselves
that if one fails then the entire
universe is
marvel didn't do this from the outset
and though we had teasers of the
avengers coming they could have easily
just kept giving us solo movies for as
long as they wanted because we didn't
expect a team up to be coming by a
certain date movies involving characters
like batman also come with big investors
behind them so if one even performs in
the mid-range then it's gonna make this
studio panic because he's such a big
name though marvel had to work with
their c team this was actually an
advantage to them because there wasn't
the mindset that these guys should be
pulling in billions every movie for
example say dc launched a new universe
with the teen titans do you think that
people are gonna view it as a failure if
it doesn't bring in billions in ticket
sales no probably not because there's no
expectations for these characters to
completely kill it on the opposite side
of this the idea of panic also massively
plays into the overall slate as well and
studios will change direction in a
second if things don't immediately go to
plan if we look at the rotten tomatoes
score for films like iron man 2 the
incredible hulk and thor they're all
good but not absolutely amazing these
three films released back to back and
they're ones that often rank lower down
the list when people are picking out
their favorite movies from the franchise
no studio is willing to sit through
back-to-back movies like this that score
in the 60s to 70s on rotten tomorrows
because they immediately expect everyone
to love their franchise buy all the toys
and take it to the next level
building a fan base takes time and we've
seen in the case of the snyder verse how
people slowly started to come around to
it rather than everyone being on board
with it from day one every studio is so
fixated on getting to be at the point
where they're at where kevin feige is
now rather than where he was they don't
understand the building blocks and slow
build that it took to get there because
marvel is such a staple now that
everyone expects to be able to copy them
instantly and gain the results that they
have fergie took several risks early on
with characters that weren't expected to
do well and he waited out whilst they
got mediocre reviews and money because
he understood the foundation that these
films would end up building every
release had its own fanbase i gravitated
towards it and though they didn't
necessarily connect with everyone there
was enough in each individual movie to
pull people in thus when avengers
launched this fan base that was spread
across multiple projects all came
together because they all had a vested
interest in what was going on so i think
in the end that studios need to do the
following if they want to succeed
firstly don't announce a massive
universe because it puts pressure on you
to have everything together and it
leaves no room for mistakes from the off
i think that matt reeves batman was
clever because they distanced themselves
from the main dc eu and because of this
there was no expectation on it to build
things up hearing now that we're getting
a sequel and some spin-off shows is a
nice surprise rather than it being
something that we feel we had to get
point two don't expect everything to be
a hit and if it's not that doesn't mean
that the universe won't work in the long
run iron man 2 incredible hulk thor and
even captain america all did okay but
what they did was get those characters
to become familiar so that we cared
about them marvel took their time didn't
put any pressure on themselves and
because of public perception these
characters also weren't expected to do
wild numbers this should be the same in
the case of all that comes as part of
dc's 10 year plan 10 years is a long
time and you need to build towards that
rather than expecting all movies to be
hits from day one there will be stumbles
falls and some that don't necessarily
work but give them room to breathe let
people come to appreciate them and don't
change direction because they don't
completely hit a home run that's why it
annoys me when studios say we will just
copy kevin foggy the man is the
blueprint but he's shown time and time
again that it's difficult to replicate
his strategy because no one has the
patience of foresight to pull off what
he did they all want instant results
won't wait it out and therein lies their
downfall as much as i want this new
tenure dc plan to do well the cynical
side of me thinks about how we've heard
this all before and so far i think that
dc have rolled out this type of strategy
three times in total that takes me to my
final point stick to the plan in the
call zazlav said that if they think a
movie is crap then they just won't
release it however this doesn't work
with shared movie universes if they're
to build towards something for example
if you take thor the dark world out the
mcu then a lot of the other movies won't
make sense they will waste countless
millions creating films just to shelve
them if they go with that ideology
they'll have to force the character
development from said movie into other
ones and it just won't work not even
marvel get every single film in their
shed universe spot on and unfortunately
you will have to put out crap but in the
long run it will all connect and make
sense i really don't think that a shared
universe and this idea of cancelling
things works which is why i'd rather
they go with standalone movies if that's
their mind state i'm begging you guys to
just take it easy let things
underperform and have confidence that
you guys are worth sifting through the
mud with so that we can get all the good
stuff down the line it's obviously going
to be very hard to do in an industry
that's so concerned with money but just
wait it out play the long game and i
promise you guys will get there that's
if you're working at dc yeah i also want
some money for coming up with this
strategy now obviously i'd love to hear
all your guys thoughts on this video
whether you agree or not and if you are
in charge exactly what you do comment
below and let me know and just to let
you know we're running a competition
right now and giving away three copies
of doctor strange in the multiverse of
madness on the 15th of august all you
have to do to be on the chance of
winning is like the video make sure you
subscribe with notifications on and drop
a comment below exactly with your
thoughts we picked the comments at
random at the end of the month and the
winners of the last one are on the
screen right now say that to you then
message me on twitter heavy spoilers if
you want something else to watch then
make sure you check out our breakdown of
prey which will be linked on screen
right now really good movie lots to talk
about for the future and definitely head
over there right after this without the
way thanks for sticking through the
video i've been poor and i'll see you
next time take care peace
you